in the last offer in the last video not
the last offering I guess it was a bit
of both we had completed our Series B we
had gone back to the tail got another
round of venture capital funding and we
raised ten million more dollars that's
going to help us build out the website
and do some marketing and hire up some
more engineers and other employees and
to do that we had to sell one really
insurance we essentially sold them at
ten dollars a share and so after that
offering all our pre-money valuation was
thirty million and our post money is now
40 million 40 million 40 million that's
the value of our assets as I mean you
know these you know the website that's
kind of an arbitrary valuation and and
I've gotten a letter asking well how do
you value that and that's a whole
subject for another playlist and I will
do that I will do a whole playlist on
valuation eventually but but but to get
there the first thing to understand is
just a capital structure and how capital
markets work in general so that's what
we're doing here but anyway so after you
got the ten million dollars you have 30
million before you get 10 million your
post money is 40 million and we have to
issue a million extra shares to do it so
before the money we had three million
and now we have four million shares so
let me draw what our balance sheet looks
like so we already had we had a million
dollars and then we raised ten million
more so if we look at the left-hand side
of our balance sheet we have 11 million
in cash 11 million in cash and we have
our website and intellectual property
maybe we have some patents now so you
can say you know assets of the firm I
guess you could say non-cash assets
right that's cash non-cash assets and
some of them could be intangibles like
branding or maybe we made some small
acquisitions of other people and well
we'll do more videos and actually the
mechanics of acquisitions and all that
but you get the idea these are all of
the other assets of the firm whatever
they may be and then on the equity side
because we have no liabilities so in
this case assets will be equal to equity
on the equity side of the equation we
just have 4 million shares 4 million
shares 1/4 went to the series B guy
right
Series B one-fourth went to the series a
guy he had bought a million dollar
million shares I think was at 750 or
share then the angel investor had given
us a million shares it and I think it
was 5 dollars a share that was the angel
and then there's me and my buddies that
we we split the last that first million
shares 5 ways and if I wanted to draw my
sliver I still have my 200,000 shares
200,000 shares and we could keep doing
that we could get a Serie C in a series
d that'll keep us going but let's say
that that a couple of other a couple of
other people have decided to sell socks
on the Internet and we realize that this
is good becoming a very competitive
space and we really wanted to just lay
down the gauntlet and and make sure that
ours is the dominant player because we
figured that whoever gets the biggest
market share fastest is going to become
the amazon.com and everyone else is
going to turn into you know these me two
players and they're all going to go out
of business so size has benefits in this
situation so we don't want to do these
piddly you know 10 million dollar
offerings and and 20 million dollar
offerings we want to go big-time we say
you know what we're going to expand our
company huge we're going to we're going
to push marketing hard and so we want to
raise a lot of money let's say let me
make up a number let's say we want to
raise I don't know we want to raise 50
million dollars
50 million dollars to invest in the
business to do some hardcore marketing
and it happens to be the time let's say
it's 1999 the stock market is racing
ahead people people would love to get in
on this kind of stuff so we said hey
let's do an initial public offering and
that has two benefits one we'll be able
to raise a lot of money for the firm to
invest in you know maybe building
distribution centers or the marketing
that I talked about and then the other
side benefit which you know we won't
really talk about much at the board
meeting but all of these people right
now they're all holding these shares
right I have these 200,000 shares this
angel investor has this million shares
and there's really not a lot they can do
with them right maybe this you know
maybe the angel investor maybe he has
some
maybe he had a expensive divorce
settlement and he has to make some
alimony payments now and he doesn't
really have the cash he can't do
anything with these shares right same
thing with these VCS these VCS are
accountable to their investors and you
know they can say like this VC could say
oh you know what I bought those shares
at 750 per share and then this guy came
and bought it at $10 per share so I
already got a 33% gain on my investment
but the investors aren't that impressed
by that because you're still holding the
shares you can't really say they're
worth $10 until you actually turn them
into $10 or you turn them into actual
cash so by doing an initial public
offering all of a sudden all of the
players will have liquidity which means
that they can exchange what they have
right including myself then they can
exchange what they have for actual cash
if they need to so how does that work so
I would go to an investment bank
although they've all turned into
commercial banks now but we're talking
in a pre-2008 world I would go to an
investment bank and I'd say or more
likely they would come to me and say hey
you guys could raise big money in the
public markets right now why don't you
do an IPO and in a few seconds you'll
realize why they are so keen to do it
and I say sure we can raise a lot of
money and it'll also you know will it'll
will be in the press so that'll be free
marketing in and of itself so say sure
do all of the work so what they'll do is
they'll be a lead underwriter let me
write that down lead underwriter and
that's essentially the person who does
all of the the legal work they're going
to write they're going to file documents
with the SEC that describe the company
and it's printed they're going to make
models and projections all that and then
they're also going to have kind of
people riding along with them other
banks and they're going to form a
syndicate a syndicate is just a group of
banks that work together to kind of
handle a larger transaction than any one
of them would be willing to handle by
themselves and it kind of spreads the
risk amongst them so that the bottom
line is what the banks do other than
doing all the legal work they'll value
the company and then they'll go to all
of their clients so all of the people
who trade through that bank all of the
institutional clients all of the hedge
funds that have their prime brokerage
accounts at those banks and just so you
know a prime brokerage account
is just like a brokerage account but
it's a brokerage account for big guys
it's a brokerage account for you know
people managing 100 million dollars and
not you know their etrade account that's
all the prime brokerage is and they'll
go to these guys and say hey we have
this hot you know this hot IPO issue Sox
calm and we've done our models and we
think this is a five billion dollar
market and we think that this company is
worth we think this company is worth at
least a hundred million dollars in its
current form so once again realize I
mean even though we're kind of doing
something a little different now all of
the other things were essentially you
could call them private offerings or
private placements in some way we were
dealing essentially these were private
equity sales and I know that word is
used a lot private equity and that's
what venture capital essentially is
although normally when people talk about
private equity they're not talking about
venture capital now I'll do a whole
other video on that but venture capital
fundamentally is private equity right
because these shares that you're selling
they're not traded on a public exchange
like the New York Stock Exchange or the
Nasdaq or something like that so anyway
back to what we were doing these guys
these banks they go to their clients and
say hey I have this hot new issue we are
and and they'll kind of gauge sentiment
they'll talk to clients they'll talk to
each other and they'd say oh you know
what the demand is and they'll
essentially come up with some price
which is essentially as high a price as
they wanted to a high price because
obviously as a company I want to sell
the stock for as much as possible but
they don't want to do it so high that
the stock doesn't trade up most banks
you want your IPO to look like this if
this is the first day of trading and
this is where this is your IPO price
they want it to look like that so that
in the future right in the future when
there's an IPO people get excited to get
in it if this IPO if the stock just did
this if it started collapsing one it'll
new people will lose interest in IPOs in
general and then people will get
suspicious about this company and I'll
do a whole video on that so why do the
mechanics work well they'll say hey you
want to raise you want to raise 50
million dollars well you can do a couple
of ways we say hey you know we're
willing to issue we're willing to issue
another let me think of the best way to
X pay we're willing to issue another 10
million shares
right and I'm not drawing it
proportionally let's say we're willing
to issue another 10 million shares and
this should be a lot higher because this
was 4 million right here
we're willing to issue another 10
million shares how much money can we get
for it and let's see these bankers
talking to essentially the market and
talking to each other they say hey we
think we can justify these guys and
we're going to do it for a little bit
lower than they're actually worth but we
think the market will by the fact that
these guys are worth I don't know let's
say they're worth I'll say 40 million oh
let me make up at 80 million dollars in
their current incarnation right which is
essentially says before we raise the
money we have 80 million dollars we have
4 million shares so they're saying $20 a
share
$20 a share so if we go in the issue
another 10 million shares at $20 a share
well actually issue will actually raise
200 million dollars actually for the
sake of so I don't have to edit my math
let's say that's how much we wanted to
raise 200 million dollars
so essentially what these guys will do
our board of directors will issue these
new shares and then these the syndicate
of banks led by the lead underwriter
will then sell it to their brokerage
clients to you know mainly institutional
investors but it might be some favored
rich guys if it's not that favorite of
an IPO maybe maybe you might get a call
as well and they'll sell it to all of
them and you say well why are they doing
that why are they being you know why are
they doing all of this work for the
company helping them raise 200 million
dollars and you know they're going to
the pain of the legal work and you're
they had to put a team of maybe 10 guys
on this and they have to make models and
it probably took them you know maybe 2
or 3 months to do it that's a lot of
work what are they going to exchange for
all of this well they actually get a
commission and that Commission at least
historically has been 7 percent of the
offering 7 percent of the offering and
now you get a sense of why it in a good
market when you can do these things
why it has in history paid to be an
investment banker because 7% of 200
million dollars and frankly it's not a
lot more work to do a 200 million dollar
offering that it is to do a 20 million
dollar offering it's probably about the
same amount
but 7% of 200 million is 14 million
dollars so actually these guys aren't
going to see 200 million they're going
to see 200 - 14 million so they're going
to see 186 million dollars and then
these bankers are going to split 14
million dollars for and that that
probably is about two months of work for
maybe ten ten guys so you can imagine
and and of course you know they have the
whole bank that has to support they have
all these you know not anyone could do
this you have to have what you know what
they call you know retail distribution
you have to have now kind of a channel
that you can you can plug these shares
into to actually get rid of the 10
million shares you see it's a fairly
profitable business so that's what an
initial public offering is is it for the
first time a company is selling shares
to the public that is not just to these
private investors and usually on an
initial public offering although it's
not always the case these guys aren't
selling their shares as much as they
would like to they're usually locked in
for a certain period just because it
looks bad if if especially the insiders
right those were the founders of the
company or actually sell their shares
and maybe but six months later then I
can go and sell my shares maybe if I do
it on a small amount I could go and sell
it on the Nasdaq and I have a publicly
traded price on any given day I know
exactly what my shares are worth and
this is an important thing to realize
because a lot of times when people buy a
stock they're like oh I've invested in
that company well kind of when you
normally buy a stock on an exchange as
you know New York Stock Exchange you're
just buying the stock from somebody else
you're not buying the stock from that
company so when you pay $100 for an IBM
stock I've run out of space that's why
I'm just talking and not drawing let me
erase this I've run out of time too but
I think it's an important point when you
buy stock from someone else so if I give
my hundred dollars and I get a stock
certificate of IBM most of the times if
I were to do this today I'm just you
know this is me with a moustache I'm
just getting it from some other dude
right well maybe he's happy because he
got a hundred dollars right got a top
hat
that's what this is and this is what
happens in the stock market every day so
when I buy that I'm not really investing
in IBM I'm just buying the money I'm
just buying that share from another guy
we're just exchanging shares in an IPO
if I'm one of the IPO investors this is
me my hundred dollars in this situation
let's say we're dealing with Sox comm so
Sox
maybe that's its ticker symbol sock this
time it's actually going to the company
it's actually going to the or the
website in this case of course of course
7% is being redirected to the investment
bankers so when you're buying from an
IPO you really are to some degree making
an investment just like if you were
doing in venture capital you really are
making an investment in the company your
money will then be used by the company
to hire people and build factories and
make out a website and do marketing in
this case you're essentially just
trading shares on a secondary in a
secondary market secondary market just
means it's not going it's not going to
the actual company it's just going to
another shareholder who bought it before
you anyway I've really gone over my time
limit so I'll see you in the next video